alright guys bangbang I have Taylor here
with us thanks for taking time to do
this yeah things are having me for sure
I feel like you have one of the coolest
jobs on the internet because you get to
sit and write about internet culture
let's just start off with kind of your
background and how do you get to that
position where we're kind of you you are
the voice of the internet culture to
some degree that's very kind
um it is definitely a dream job
I always tell teenagers that reach out
like it's you know a job that you get to
spend all day on YouTube or tik-tok or
zoom now but I got into media actually
about a decade ago through tumblr I in
2009 after graduating in college I was
just working a bunch of temp jobs and
got into tumblr and that's kind of what
got me into media doing social media and
I spent most of my career running social
media accounts for brands and writing on
the side and then about three years ago
transitioned to writing about this stuff
full-time and so as you think about like
internet culture itself maybe just start
with like what does that mean to you
given you spend so much time
understanding it yeah um you know I
think internet culture is like what an
internet culture reporter I think is
gonna be one of those job titles that's
like webmaster where it kind of will
probably seem irrelevant because every
year I feel like the Internet is just
more ingrained in our lives especially
now in the midst of a pandemic we're
literally living online so I kind of
think of it as culture coverage with a
tech bent my technical title at the New
York Times is technology reporter and I
definitely love tech and you know look
at things sort of look at how people
socialize and how culture moves through
these platforms like so any any kind of
social platform that can be you know
something that's made to be a social
platform like Facebook Instagram Twitter
or something that you know another type
of technology that people are just using
to connect and socialize like Google
Docs or zoom or things like that yeah
and it feels almost like you know the
internet culture is actually really
become it used to drive culture now it's
almost becoming thug culture right
there's less and less of a difference
between the two to some degree I think
there's almost no distinction I mean I
do think that you have some people that
are still kind of offline and in certain
ways but you know it's it's even true
for older people I mean if you think of
boomer culture it's very driven by the
internet old people love memes more than
anyone you know boomers are very online
in other ways usually email so yeah it's
definitely kind of just culture at this
point especially pop culture I mean the
areas that I cover in terms of like
entertainment or music or movies Netflix
it's it's yeah it's just culture
coverage which is why I'm on the Style
section of the New York Times which is
our call you know we sort of cover life
style and culture and things like that
rather than being on like the business
side where I'm covering more of the
business of tech companies for sure and
one of my favorite sayings right now I
was like the memes are the message right
kind of taking the bend of like the
medium is the message maybe talk a
little bit just about how you see
whether it is beams or gifts and things
like that how they're infiltrating a lot
of society yeah well I think that's a
society we're moving towards visual
communication and that's been true for a
while I mean memes have been around for
I think 20 years I went to some
retrospective at the Museum of Moving
Image in New York on memes and I was
honestly surprised I think the first
meme they had was like what all your
base belong to us or something it was
like literally from the year 2000 so you
know the concept of memes as we
understand them is these kind of like
internet pieces of content communicating
a message have been around for a while
and you know we're also using platforms
that allow us that allow us to express
ourselves more visually you know like
Instagram stories all the creative
tools we have there snapchat now
tick-tock you can express yourself in
this very visual way which lends itself
to memes and just as things travel
around the internet they gain kind of
this shared understanding or knowledge
or humor to them and so I think it's
just easier to kind of share and riff
off people's thoughts or content or
ideas and it's you know it's just easier
to do that I can't speak it's a lot more
easy to do that every day for certain
and it feels like you of all people like
if somebody said to me who has the best
pulse on the younger generations on a
lot of these platforms like I think you
are probably the first person that comes
to mind for many people so maybe let's
just start with going how you think
about each platform for the younger
generation right so there's snapchat
there's tick tock there's Twitter to
some you know bit but just like how do
you think about how they're using each
one of those platforms differently I'm
in comparison to each other um I mean I
guess I would say the main difference
that I see what young people is just the
extent to which they use it I mean if
you think about Instagram sorry if you
think about Instagram a lot of
Millennials or older users tweet
Instagram they treat the products sort
of the way that that they understood the
product when they initially got on it
sometimes like in 2013 2014 when it was
really primarily a photo sharing app
whereas younger people that's really
sort of where the they it's like the
core of where they express their
identity and their friendships and stuff
like that so it's much more of a
communication app I mean snapchat is
another one that I think older users
kind of stopped embracing but it's still
like a primary messaging app for a lot
of young people and tik-tok I kind of
compared a lot to Twitter actually
because it is a place where especially
young people will go to express their
ideas it's almost like a mini YouTube in
the sense that you can make these short
videos they can get surfaced and go
viral but you know you can also live
stream you can also comment you can also
DM it has a lot of other kind of
capabilities too but sort of like
Twitter it's like where I think that
while a lot of older people might go to
Twitter to express their thoughts on
maybe the President or something younger
kids will tend to do that on to talk
yeah
but they usually tweet about like stands
you know Billy I'll ice or something for
sure and it feels like you know there's
a entire culture on these platforms
right so like tick tock refer is a great
example where there's obviously the tick
tock influencers there are certain ways
that people use it and you wrote an
article about even the way that people
use certain functionality and one of
them was like the live-streaming while
people are sleeping maybe talk a little
bit about just like that seems like such
like a nuance to use case for a platform
where most older people would like be
horrified at the idea of that whereas
some of these influencers had really
kind of understood like hey this is a
unique way to use the platform yeah it's
funny so back in 2015 I was obsessed
with this live streaming app called you
now and I would make my friends go on it
all the time it never honestly really
took off but there was there were you
know influencers some of them became
users that are not tick talkers but um
you know it was another live streaming
platform where the benefit was to sort
of stream as long as possible but
obviously it's very hard to fill content
for that amount of hours then there was
this this trend that started called
sleep squad that took off among people
and it kind of became this thing that
people did which is livestream
themselves sleeping um and then now we
see it on Twitch and tick tock and it's
kind of a thing it's kind of a meme but
it's a joke it's like can I hey how many
followers can I get you know when I'm
sleeping but it's also a way to like go
viral because it's so funny and because
what it does is provide these sort of
pop-up chat rooms so it's like it's kind
of like a lot of people also just stream
an inanimate object and what they're
doing is really just they want to get
that like chat going and then people
just start connecting and chatting and
having this whole thing through within
this pop-up chat on the live stream and
so that
the appeal for users that are watching
it it's not that yeah it's a darkroom
someone sleeping and that's kind of
funny for a second but you're also able
to kind of like chat you know with these
other people in a way that you wouldn't
you know have access to so it's sort of
like these little ephemeral chat rooms
yeah and it seems like as part of that
these applications aren't being used
solely for the videos right so like the
tick-tocks for example you can sit and I
think it's really unique how I put the
platform together in terms of you kind
of just scroll and and continue to see
video after video after video and if
you're just using it for the first
couple of times like that's kind of the
surface use case but the comments and
kind of all of these subcultures within
the platform aren't very obvious is that
something going back to like the younger
demographic is just all of their friends
are doing it and they kind of learn it
by talking to each other or is it
something that you just actually like
the time on the application itself
drives you to use some of the other
features you know that's something that
I would love like data from Instagram on
for instance I wrote about like comment
culture on Instagram a couple years ago
and it's hugely driven by teenagers I
mean if you go in the comments of a lot
of stuff it's like meme accounts people
trying to get you know publicity and
then a lot of teenagers or young people
primarily I mean of course they're still
like you know other it's not just
teenagers that comment but but they
really do engage in that way um and I
don't know I you know I don't know if
that just has to I don't know if it's
driven specifically by time spent but I
imagine part of it is the culture like
tagging friends responding to things and
I think a lot of young you know stars on
Instagram also have more interesting
comment sections yeah I mean it feels
like you know and instagrams I think a
perfect example where you see the
comments but then there's also like a
whole nother layer of usage where people
take the photos or videos that are
posted they DM them into these groups
and they have these group chats around
that and it's like that conversation is
more protected it's private it's with
that kind of a selective group of
friends but that
there's almost the same type of thing
that happens in the comments to some
degree yeah I mean I think both are
places to socialize I mean the benefit
of Dion is that you can share links you
know you have a set group of people I
hear of people meeting in the comments a
lot and I think there's like somebody
that was saying that they met friends
actually in the comments of the comments
by celeb page because there's all these
like comments by accounts now that are
really popular to that sort of highlight
some of the best parts the comments
section so I think people are kind of
going there to make connections find
people with similar interests and then
hop into group chats there's so many
interest based group chats you know that
people are involved in on Instagram and
I get added to them a lot and I love it
and so I just yeah I just think it's
another way to socialize I think that
you know a lot of users that are maybe
more adults I don't know someone I mean
I know some moms that have Instagram
group chats but I think they're also
more likely to use things like iMessage
yes speaking of moms one of the the
trends that just blows me away is on
tick tock these kids who are pulling
their parents and especially now because
most of them are home and their parents
are growing like pretty big audiences
simply by dancing in videos with their
kids right somewhere to kind of think
how about vine stars all made each other
famous now kids are just doing it with
like the closest adults them who just
happens to be their middle-aged parent I
know I wrote a piece of couple weeks ago
about sort of like how it's all family
tick-tock now because everyone's
involving every member of their family I
saw a girl just this morning celebrating
she was giving her father a cake because
he had it a hundred thousand so it's
yeah it's it's been fun I think
everybody you know when you like an
influencer or you like a certain person
on ticket talk you like to kind of
follow everyone in their orbit whether
that's their close friends or their
family their family usually are the ones
that have the kind of like
behind-the-scenes access to them and
posts you know funny videos and and you
know a bunch of the big ticket talk
influencers have kind of transformed
their whole family into influencers like
Addison Rae her whole family and Charlie
D'Amelio obviously like Mark D'Amelio is
like
once around himself now yeah and I guess
part of that it's Charlie D'Amelio is I
think one of the first ones that I saw
where she's now got fifty million
followers give or take ah yeah Wow and
and so she's famous her sister's famous
her dad's famous and her mom's saying
it's rhymey literally the entire family
and then they all got signed by UTA
together like as a unit so maybe let's
talk a little bit just about like the
business behind a lot of this cuz it's
you know it's kind of fun in games to
see people post the content and grow but
there's really really big businesses
that are being built here just kind of
had a high level like how do you think
about you know the commercialization or
the business behind all of it
yeah I think that's what a lot of people
sort of don't understand is the business
behind it and one how much work it takes
to grow that business and to this sort
of like ancillary businesses that are
built up around the influencer industry
I mean you mentioned agents a lot you
know the big Hollywood agencies all have
very robust digital divisions that sign
you know people like the D'Amelio so
hoping to turn them into essentially the
next Kardashians or sort of growth you
know grow their brand even bigger
collectively but then you also have all
of these other people that's support
influencers you know you have kids that
just make money essentially by helping
influencers optimize their YouTube
thumbnails and editing them in a certain
way to get them clicks or you have you
know somebody that runs a brand
marketing platform that just partners
brands with influencers there's like a
lot of sort of businesses that are
helped is through so we've set up to
help support the influencer economy it's
not just like traditional entertainment
businesses like managers agents you know
acting coaches singing coach just a lot
of these people have those people also
in network but yeah it's it's crazy
because I think you know when you get
into the game of hey just creating
content one thing but Nelson we're gonna
start optimizing the thumbnail right
we're actually going to strategically
place you in videos with other
influencers to cross-promote
accounts and and it almost feels like a
lot of this loses the authenticity but
the ones who are really good at
they're able to kind of hide the
business a little bit behind this how
much of that is being driven by the kids
themselves and like they want it to be a
business versus they've got a family
member or somebody near them who's a
little bit more professional or you know
experience that that's driving it yeah
their family members absolutely are
never more experienced than these kids
these kids understand monetization on
digital platforms better than truly I
would say almost any digital marketing
executive a lot of them and if you look
at people like David Goldberg or James
Charles Wright both of whom are very
young influencers you know they're not
teenagers I think James is like 20 in
David's 23 or something you know they
are they have teams around them but
they're incredibly adapt at staying on
top of the trends you know getting in
early and promoting themselves on these
new platforms growing their audiences
and they really do want to make it a
full-time career and that's it's you
know I would say being an influencer or
content creator or whatever you're
essentially an entrepreneur right you're
running your own small business often
that that business is your personal
brand but you know it can also just be
an interest-based
account that you run you know if you're
a car vlogger and you just post about
cars all day you know you can end up
sort of running essentially a little
content company about cars right um and
so I think like any small business owner
you know these people work really hard
they understand their business better
than anyone and it's usually it's driven
from them because if you have some
outside person you know that can help
motivate you to a point but it really
has to come from you if you want the
businesses yeah and it would it be fair
to say that a lot of these young kids
like this is the dream right when I was
growing up it was like hey I want to go
play in the NBA or play for professional
sports people would be wanted to be like
a traditional actor or a musician it
feels like now there's a lot of these
kids were saying like no I actually want
to be an influencer or like that is
something to aspire to be as a career
yeah absolutely I think it's like the
number one thing a lot of kids aspire to
be I saw some stupid thing that was
going around last year of like oh and
some other country kids want to be an
not in America they want to be a
youtuber and you know people will share
that and they sort of joke about it
which I get but you know if you're a
youtuber well one that's that's the work
that you're seeing modeled every day you
know when you log on the internet you're
following people that you know these
that are talking about their job every
day like you know these youtubers are
talking about what it's like to be a
youtuber how they're making money you
know they'll give a behind-the-scenes
tour of like you know the the factory
that's developing their merch or things
like that so they're talking about that
career in a really detailed way to kids
in a way that honestly be a lot of kids
don't have any clue what their parents
do but they deeply understand sort of
like how an influencer business works um
so that's part of it I think is why they
think it's aspirational it'sit's the
main version of work that they're seeing
on the internet every day and then to UM
you know there's a huge amount of at
economy that comes with running your own
business a lot of people mistake wanting
to be an influencer or with wanting Fame
but a lot of these kids what they want
is they want autonomy and they want to
be able to run their own company based
off their own interests so if you know
if you can run a small business that's
you know gets you access to certain
events maybe because you know you you're
involved in some world you know I'll use
cars is another example cuz I know this
this kid I can't remember his name
buddies on YouTube he's very into cars
right like you know in the past maybe he
would have been a car journalist to be
honest but you know he makes all of
these really cool driving videos he gets
to test cars before anyone else he gets
to work with all these major car brands
that's the dream job you know um and you
own your income you set your own hours
you have enormous flexibility I can't
imagine why you would want to do you
know some entry-level job instead of
sort of owning your own thing yeah it's
almost like the barriers to entry are so
low because literally you know you've
got a cellphone in your hand can you
record a video posted on one of these
platforms and if you're good at it all
of a sudden you can be in the audience
and it goes from there and another piece
that you know in conversations I have
with people who are trying to understand
this stuff I always say like this isn't
new either right I mean if you look at
Oprah Tony Robbins
all these people basically were the
influencers before we called them
influencers they just had to do it on
different platforms it took a lot more
capital and that do most of these
younger kids understand that kind of
this isn't new it's just in a new form
factor or they just so focused on what
they're doing that they don't really
kind of make the historical connection
yeah I mean I think Oprah is different
because she's more of a traditional
celebrity and so there's all these sort
of gatekeepers right before getting
there and I don't think that she really
owned her own IP and business from the
start
Tony Robbins might be a better example I
mean I think some people in certain
careers right he's an entrepreneur
ultimately um so yeah I think that
what's different is that you know it's
people building themselves up on this
digital platforms and sort of owning
their followers um and you're right that
is not new I mean it's funny when I did
this story recently on agency as I was
talking to this guy from Abrams which is
a big sort of talent agency and they
were signing myspace stars back in 2006
um so I think it took a while for it to
emerge I mean I got my start on tumblr
and you know there were certainly other
people that were very big on tumblr at
the time that I was that have sort of
launched careers from that um but it's
just it's more pervasive now I think you
know every year kids are more and more
sort of on the internet these social
platforms get more power and so I think
that it sort of progressed into
mainstream culture and a different way
just the fact that I have a job covering
this stuff you know I couldn't get a job
I tried for a long time to write about
this stuff full-time and there really
wasn't an audience I would say until
three years ago so you know I think it's
entering the mainstream in in a
different way yes speaking of entering
the mainstream like how many these kids
want to stay on the digital platforms
right so be the tic-tock influence or
whatever versus they want to cross over
into like traditional movies commercials
television shows and things that maybe
we think it's more traditional media
like do they actually want to cross over
or is it they shun that and they want to
send the digital platform totally I
don't think they think of themselves
that's like specific to platforms like a
lot of kids that come up on tik-tok they
have I mean they all have different
career aspirations but what they want is
to own their own business
brands um I think that you know I was
talking to this 18-year old tic-tock
reader recently and he's been offered a
you know potential show of his own and
he's just like well that's gonna impede
on my YouTube show you know and if you
and the YouTube show you see direct
benefits you'reyou're able to monetize
that you get to add money you know the
follow the people that watch become your
followers and you grow when you when you
go on a TV network first of all it's
hard for people to find you know unless
it's a big enough show it's kind of not
worth it so I think it really depends it
also depends on whether these kids want
to go into entertainment entertainment
is really only a portion of the
influencer economy right you have a lot
of other people where you know their
dream is to launch a fashion brand right
or you're a beauty influencer you really
want to like productize yourself and
launch your own beauty brand maybe that
maybe that means like going on a fashion
maybe Project Runway or something but
ultimately like your goal isn't to be an
actress or a singer so I think for those
you know the small portion that does
want to be maybe a traditional Hollywood
person it's a huge it's a huge step up
to have a following and you'll
definitely get in the door faster than
people without a following but the
majority of kids that I talk to it's not
that they want to stay on digital
platforms forever they just want to own
their own thing and I think they see as
sometimes like doing these bigger deals
with more traditional platforms as kind
of like giving up some of that control
yeah and it's really interesting that
you see them as entrepreneurs because I
think that's like a very unique lens and
it would make sense that if you are that
entrepreneur you want to build the brand
and kind of drive the the business that
you have you don't want to go get
distracted right so like that wouldn't
make sense but how do they actually make
money right so like there's a whole
bunch of things that I've heard but like
in your experience and what are the main
revenue sources for somebody who's amass
one of these audiences on the digital
platforms yeah you know kind of like
every small business they all have sort
of a mix of different revenue streams
there's no one way that all influencers
monetize the primary way that people
usually the primary thing that people
think of when they
of influencers is usually brand deals
the assumption is that influencers just
make money by posting spank on all day
sponsored content that's not really true
certainly some influencers do make money
from brand deals I mean most most
influencers that that's a huge portion
of their revenue stream um but you know
they're also making money on pre-roll
ads for instance on YouTube merch has
really emerged in the past I would say
since 2018 really when fan joy came on
the market and started working with a
lot of the top youtubers um merch has
become the primary revenue driver i mean
david dobrik for instance one of the
most popular youtubers in the world
makes hardly any money on youtube but he
makes his money through selling merch
and through this clothing brand that
he's developed called clickbait um you
know so launching your own merchandise
and product lines are really big so
you'll sort of either license your name
or work with a company to you know
develop a line for instance for
Nordstrom where you you know take a
portion of that profit or you develop
your own product for instance this girl
gal meets glam julia angle she's a huge
lifestyle influencer develop this very
sort of southern unique style and
launched her own clothing line and it's
now you know massively successful I mean
she's still an influencer but that's
that's the way she makes all of her
money she essentially runs a clothing
brand um so you're seeing more and more
of that again the influencers are trying
to keep control and they want to
directly monetize their audience and
they don't want to partner with someone
or rely on some ad dollars that could go
away tomorrow a lot more of them - were
charging for exclusive behind-the-scenes
access so that could be charging people
for close friends content on Instagram
or setting up a patreon launching the
podcast having a newsletter where you
give exclusive you know photos or videos
things like that these are there's a
million other things but those are kind
of all the big ones and do they work
that from like seeing a Kylie Jenner go
and create the kind of lip kitten and
her whole line of products or a Kanye
West really license his name essentially
to create ease ease with adidas like or
they seeing that and saying I basically
want to do that in my own world or these
you know again they're just not
necessarily making that connection
between what they're doing and what some
of these much more traditional memories
I think that the influencers are
pioneering that you know you see people
like Kylie Jenner take that model
because influencers pioneered that model
you know growing this digital platform
and then turning it into a you know
using it to launch a product or do
something like that like that that is
classic sort of influence or
monetization strategy I think they're
really successful especially young
celebrities are monetizing that way and
copying these influencers um in terms of
Licensing I mean celebrities have always
license their name so I think that's
probably a more traditional business but
you know you see even this actresses now
charging for close friends content you
know that was something that was started
by people on the internet so um you know
I think it actually flows the other way
more than you think
where you have these groups of people
online pioneering new monetization
strategies and then it sort of ladders
up as bigger bigger people adopt it it
almost feels like just like in
technology innovations the necessity of
you know comes from necessity right they
don't have the the big teams and stuff
you've mentioned a couple of times the
close friends Instagram content I'm
assuming most people listening don't
know what that is and it's fascinating
so we just talk a little bit about like
how an influencer or celebrity uses that
functionality on Instagram to monetize
sure um so close friends is essentially
this feature on Instagram where you can
just put post content on your Instagram
stories just to a select group of people
that you select um you know influencers
adopted it because it's just another way
to get your content behind sort of a
paywall so you know people charge maybe
yeah the influencer will charge maybe
three dollars a month and if you pay
that or you support them at that level
on patreon you'll get access to you
those additional videos posted to
Instagram stories that are only you know
gated to close friends um I wrote a
piece a couple years ago on like
up-and-coming rappers and like sort of
SoundCloud
Bru's and how they pioneered monetizing
every single feature on Instagram and I
think it's an example of this kind of
like ground up like I guess like these
monetization strategies where these
these rappers are essentially charging
for literally every single thing I mean
they'll charge post they'll charge like
they'll charge to comment you know if
you're a fan and you want me to comment
like great you know that's gonna be five
dollars from you or whatever I mean if
you think about it like cameo is kind of
built office right like asking for
shoutouts from certain celebrities um
you know prior to cameo people were just
negotiating these things on Instagram so
yeah so I think that it's you know that
should that kind of those kind of
monetization strategies are definitely
things that influencers have pioneered
really people on the Internet of play I
mean a lot of these rappers a lot of
snacks workers a lot of other people
that have been shut up shut out for more
traditional forms of monetization have
developed these sort of other schemes
that have been more widely adopted yeah
and maybe talk a little bit about how
these influencers like work together to
grow their audiences so we saw you know
the vine stars all lived in the same
apartment complex pull each other in
I've heard of Instagram groups where
like if we're all in the same group I
post i DM it into the group everyone
goes and likes and comments on it just
like what do you see there and is that
becoming more pervasive where people
realize like hey let me team up with
other influencers and really grow our
audiences together yeah you know it's I
would say people constantly
underestimate collaboration when it
comes to growth because if you're
collaborating with the right people
you're gonna grow and I think what you
see is a lot of people have come up this
way I mean I was a big fan of o2 L which
was this youtuber group back in the day
like 2012 and you know that was
essentially this group of guys that met
at VidCon and decided to kind of all
partner up and create videos together
you know essentially every day of the
week in this collaborative channel and
grew huge and you know you see vlogs
wide you mentioned the vine generation
like you have to kind of partner up and
collaborate on content in general
because just posting videos of yourself
gets old you want people in your orbit
and if you can find sort of
they're like-minded people it just it it
makes your content more sticky and
engaging you know because even if I like
you know you for instance maybe I follow
you on YouTube and then you constantly
have your friend Joe in the video even
if I'm not like a huge fan of Joe I
might just follow Joe anyway because
he's friends with you and so it's just
kind of this way to grow your influence
and also you know help others you know
build up others and don't build up you
yeah and so this then led into these
hype houses or content houses like
explain what these are and kind of like
what the hell is going on with a bunch
of teenagers all living in the same yeah
well again just you know these have been
around for almost a decade
like the o2l how's the vlog squad had a
house that you mentioned sixteen hundred
vine which was back in 2013 this
apartment complex that all these miners
lived in so creators have always sort of
lived together in these collaborative
houses in mostly Los Angeles but there
are kind of all over I mean the original
phase house um was in New York I think
actually um so it's it's great to kind
of like live with people that you
collaborate with it provides more
opportunity for content usually when
you're coming up you can't live in your
own apartment you know you can't live by
yourself so it's cheaper to live with
other up-and-coming creators that have
the same goals it's you and you know you
see this kind of thing happened in the
comics the world right or actors that
start out living together but I think
with the tic-tock generation they grew
up seeing all of these collab houses on
YouTube and wanting to emulate that
lifestyle that you know as soon as they
have any amount of money in cloud they
want to move to LA and start something
like the hype house for instance which
is this tick-tock or collective now you
have the sway house you know there's the
clubhouse which is you know bunch of
people that left the hype house and and
sort of and so on and so forth there's a
lot of them um you know Jake Paul had
his team 10
there was the cloud house these sort of
these places serve as little hubs almost
and they're not just for the influencers
that live there
they're for other people and that kind
of generation of stars to come over and
collaborate hangout people to stay you
know places for people to stay out here
in town
yeah and my understanding is that
there's not a lot of kind of hardware or
infrastructure that's in the houses so
that these people are using but maybe
just talk about like somebody who's got
you know 50 million followers even a
million followers like are they
literally just using their cell phone to
do all this or is there a little bit
more that goes into the production that
that might not be as obvious to people
just watching the content yeah I mean
it's I mean with tick tock it's
cellphone maybe your ring light maybe a
stand although at the hype house
when I was there in January they were
using literally about a smart water
bottle and a toilet paper roll as their
default stand to film all their videos
so I think it's a lot more low five and
people would probably imagine sometimes
you'll have like a DSLR to film YouTube
content but a lot of times people like
the sort of more authentic raw way it
looks um if you film it with an iPhone
and it's just easier a lot of kids I see
just edit it all on their phone which is
insane but that's that's more for
content on you know YouTube and
Instagram if you're doing something with
more higher production value maybe for
YouTube you know sometimes you'll shoot
with a camera but it's not like you have
a massive production crew with like a TV
camera or anything like that does that
make it harder for either the
traditional players or you know folks
you want to bring this stuff to
television and try to recreate it but it
isn't necessary authentic to them does
that make it harder for them to because
they're used to coming with you know 10
people in a crew and lighting and TV
cameras and all of that yeah I mean I
think you know people always reach out
to me cuz I think over the years people
have wanted to do different reality
shows I think that it's I mean Jake Paul
had his team ten essentially a reality
show on YouTube and I think that he did
have maybe a part of a production crew
for that or like he had you know he it
was definitely more highly produced than
normal content a lot of big youtubers
have you know specific editors and
they'll have maybe like a boom mic or
something um but I think it's I think
it's probably you know I don't know I
don't really know anything about the TV
world I think they would probably be
shocked at how lo-fi a lot of stuff
is that I don't even know what is
required for TV because I'm so out of
touch with the TV but it's crazy right
like literally you're talking about
people who you know as you said they
have a good toilet paper roll right and
they're using that as a stand and they
actually are probably getting more views
on some of the content than traditional
television shows and so the world has
kind of really really changed and that
you also wrote this piece on like the
American teenager bedroom and like how
that's kind of changed and almost become
like a headquarters for a lot of the
stuff maybe talk just like what exactly
does that mean
right yeah I profiled this 15 year old
kid Rowan winch who is a little
entrepreneur he ran a bunch of meme
accounts which is another thing that
teenagers do to kind of get clout and
followers on the Internet
and I do think a lot of people are doing
a lot of this stuff in their bedroom I
mean the more entertainment like
personal brands people may move to LA
but then you have this whole generation
of young kids that is getting into
things like e-commerce right like drop
shipping using meme accounts growing
meme accounts to promote that which is
essentially influencer marketing right
growing digital brands and kind of
engaging in the internet and promoting
yourself in the internet but they're not
necessarily doing it like with their own
face on it and that's kind of what I was
interested in is just like how these
kids are running these little companies
from their bedrooms and how challenging
that is one to manage when you're young
and to just help also this because you
have no I mean none of these kids have
any contact with the platforms there's
usually doing stuff that's technically
violating some you know terms of service
like growth hacking type spam stuff and
you know so yeah that's that was what I
guess was interesting to me and why I
want to write about that yeah it feels
like again you know not new in the sense
that there's always been kids who have
had their little side hustles you know
really just trying to get some cash it's
kind of that even when I was growing up
whether it was selling you know things
that you had selling sneakers going and
buying and stuff but then the internet
opened it
like hey I cannot sell to anybody in the
world these kids taken an even step
further whereas their even maybe 5-10
years ago let's say merchandise for
example you would have to literally put
an order in you know take risk upfront
get the actual inventory and then try to
sell it and if you sold it great but if
not the year that's holding you know but
just white shirts that you don't want
drop shipping and things like that
obviously changed that and it feels like
these kids really really understand the
logistical side of this and the true
business behind it it's not just hey
I've got an account let me you know just
turn a switch on and all said money
starts pouring in right no they're so
sophisticated in terms of their
marketing
I mean branding understanding of
e-commerce understanding of like
promotion and digital marketing in
general I mean that doesn't mean that
they don't make constant missteps I mean
I think a lot of kids are always do
maybe on Instagram because they're
getting banned or blocked or you know
they're got kicked off Shopify for
something but it you know it is it is I
think it's great that all these kids are
sort of learning that stuff and it is
through through this influencer culture
I mean it's it's sort of like wanting to
be an entrepreneur and wanting to own
your own thing and leveraging the
attention economy to you know get you
there yeah and I guess as part of that
like if you're a traditional business
you not only are very good at kind of
your business yourself but you also are
probably pretty good at measuring are
you being successful or not are you
growing is revenue going up or down you
know what's your cost of acquisition all
these metrics that we're almost going
like an investor report do they have any
understanding of that stuff or is it
more of just okay so they from a data
driven standpoint they're actually
pretty sophisticated oh my god these
kids I was literally on the phone with
this 19 year old who runs a really
popular give away company with a 16 year
old and they so you know they
orchestrate these massive Instagram
giveaways which are essentially growth
marketing you know tactics for
influencers that they sort of have an
influencer that that hosts a cash
giveaway and then they sell spots worth
basically if to follow these 70 accounts
you know to enter the giveaway and then
they'll charge all those 70 accounts to
be part of it and make money on top
that and yeah this teenager was just
explaining to me you know the difference
in CPMs in all of these different forms
of advertising and why giveaways are you
know currently the highest but you know
you have to get this kind of thing and
how you know he has these calculations
that he is determined in terms of how
many followers each person you know each
sponsor can expect and how that affects
his pricing and you know this is a kid
that is I believe a freshman or
sophomore in college and I truly and
sometimes I'm like why are these why are
you even in school I understand wanting
a degree but I I think and his 16 year
old partner you know it'll be
interesting to see if he goes to school
but you know even if their business
fails because you know the giveaway
bubble is definitely a thing on
Instagram right now and I don't think
it'll be there forever you you know you
have this really deep understanding of
analytics and Instagram and you know
advertising basically so yeah and I
guess one of the reasons why kid would
still be in school even though they're
doing this making money is because their
parents right here probably in to some
degree saying like hey you're gonna go
to school what is the parents reaction
to a lot of this like are they
supportive of their kids are they you
know scared shitless and saying like I
can't believe my kid is gonna play
around on the Internet and somehow
money's showing up what do they just
generally think yeah and by the way I
think kids should go to school anyway I
think a lot of kids I talk to go there
for social reasons too it's fun to be in
college you know even if you don't have
you know if you don't ever go to class
it's still fun and if you're making
money and you can afford to pay for
yourself or get a scholarship that's
great um you know a lot of parents that
I talked you on don't understand this
stuff at all I mean it's it's the you
know Rowan's mother was very shocked by
a lot of it I think he was also keeping
money as a lot of kids do in PayPal
accounts so you can keep money in PayPal
you know never transfer it to a bank and
then use it all these teen retailers
accept paypal
see you kind of don't have to let your
parents know necessarily the amount of
money coming in you're not claiming it
on taxes so I think some parents are you
know worried about that
no Romans mom was like where is he
getting this money this is suspicious
but you know once realizing that you
know her son was doing running this work
like businesses was like that's I'm
really proud just save it
I always tell kids to save their money
as well most kids don't I have to tell
you the majority of kids that I talk to
you make some kind of financial misstep
which i think is it's good to make that
you know those mistakes when you're
young when you're a teenager and you're
you know quality of life is not gonna
meaningfully change um you know some
kids also use it to help pay their
parents rent or cover medical costs for
their parents or whatever even though
their parents need so I think a lot of
parents are grateful when they see their
kids making money you know just the way
they would if their kid went out and got
a part-time job somewhere else yeah it's
pretty cool obviously I think you and I
have a very rosy perspective of a lot of
this and we generally are fans of it and
understand why it's happening but
there's also kind of a dark side to a
lot of it first like what is like the
bad behavior look like from the adults
right so whether it's parents stepping
in and like taking the kids money or
doing anything like that or even like
the agents and people who realize hey
you know you're an influencer you've got
a big audience like let me quote unquote
help you but that help really is just
help me make money off of you rather
than truly help you like you see any of
that happening well I had to tell you
not from the big agencies I mean like
UTI ACA I mean it is like a huge sign of
achievement for a lot of kids to work
with those big agencies because of the
deals that they get them and I haven't
seen a lot of parents taking advantage
of kids to be honest a lot of these kids
are more sophisticated than their
parents when it comes to Internet but I
do see sort of predatory managers come
in a lot of the time you know you see
these management companies or management
collectives come in sign kids to bad
contracts promise them the world and
really kind of act like vultures that is
what is really disturbing I you know I
saw one contract recently that's
somebody leaked to me that I showed to
an entertainment lawyer and he was like
this is the most unethical contract I've
ever seen and you know there are these
big kids out there that have signed it
and you know so I think it's stuff like
that that is upsetting I think that the
entertainment industry is always preyed
on young people unfortunately so in that
sense you know these people are not new
these people were scamming wannabe
models and actresses before all of this
the good thing is that a lot of times
you know these kids have their
followings and so that's good as long as
they don't sign away their IP or
something like they you know can at
least have their following sometimes to
kind of negotiate back on some of these
people but yeah that's that's kind of
bad I mean there's also the actual
scammer so like people that are
constantly trying to hack these kids
take down you know get them taken down
there's all the drama accounts that feed
off of drama between these kids and
start feuds and it can get really toxic
really quickly I mean a lot of kids end
up quitting because of bullying you know
it's mentally exhausting to all day so I
would say there's like a lot of sort of
bad mental health stuff that can happen
to you as well I mean burnout is huge
yeah what like with the contract where
you say like it's unethical like any
kind of specific things that are in
there or just generally like it's
obvious that someone's taking advantage
of somebody else
yes obvious somebody's taking advantage
of somebody else I mean I well first
I'll give you a public case that I wrote
about as well which was the t ththugh
lawsuit against faze clan last year
right like t ththugh one of the best
fort night players in the world had
signed to faze clan one of the best
esports sort of dislike influence our
collective esports conglomerate you know
that lives in this massive house in LA
content creators and you know teeth who
rightly sued to get out of that contract
because in some cases they were taking
up to 80% of his revenue for certain
things and certain you know winnings was
you know he got really bad splits and
he's like look I'm the number one for
tonight player in the world right now
and yeah maybe faze clan helped me get
there a little bit by
motion but these are really bad terms
and you know that actually caused phase
to completely revamp all of their
contracts with talent so you know I
think you kind of need at least one
influencer to be like a whistleblower if
they're in this kind of bad situations
or working with bad management um I
think these tried to do the right thing
because they realized that you know
whatever but they're I don't know the
the lawsuit was sort of ongoing they
definitely got people into some bad
contracts with some of these tick
talkers they're just so excited to be in
LA and they're very swept up by this
lifestyle and I think they're promised a
lot of things and so they'll sign away
you know rights to their content for
instance not really understanding what a
big deal that is yeah it's pretty sad
too because the the kids in many cases
probably don't actually understand it
right so it's one thing if you enter a
contract and you understand what you're
signing and then maybe later you have
regrets like okay that's just kind of
you know the part of business but when
you sign something you don't understand
it and then all of a sudden you realize
hey I made you know a million dollars
last year but 800,000 of it I didn't see
and then I got to pay taxes on 200k like
that's probably not the best situation
and it's the kids you know it's not the
kids with for instance mark D'Amelio as
a father who understands this kind of
stuff it's kids that often have more
working-class families their parents are
not you know they don't know a lawyer
for instance that can take a look at it
for them and it's so it is it's really
it's it's a bummer you know how many
people are taken advantage of and that's
sort of like I said always been true in
that attainment industry as well you
know with up-and-coming models and other
people it's just yeah you recently wrote
about strip clubs on Instagram yeah well
you know like everything else in the
pandemic so our strip clubs and so I
wrote about how you know they've kind of
been reimagined on Instagram there is
this guy Justin Laboy and Justin combs
p-diddy son who were hosting this thing
called demon time sort of this Instagram
wide strip club show I literally was
surprised I got it into the times
because like the times can be kind of
prude about that stuff but yes basically
just you know women stripping on
Instagram live during these sort of
pop-up shows obviously the handle gets
banned immediately so they'll kind of
create a new handle for each show and
you know they pin the girls cash up and
then the girl you know essentially makes
money through tips from Akasha and since
they started doing it the this guy Tory
Lanez copied them and started this thing
called quarantine radio where he was
kind of also letting women dance and
then magic City big strip club in
Atlanta also was offering virtual lap
dances basically this woman dancing on
Instagram stories for you it's pretty
crazy how it also falls in line with
other tech trends though right like we
all see kind of these virtual worlds
popping up and so like I don't know if
anyone expected
strip clubs to go virtual right because
of a quarantine but it does fit within
more and more things going online and
you can quickly see how if they can
figure out the monetization they can
figure out their way around a lot of the
platforms right and that's another piece
is just like constant cat-and-mouse game
between the platforms and a lot of these
creators
trying to please something like this
versus the kid who just gets reported
you know in sexually a bullying
situation how do you know who to take
down who not to take down but it feels
like it's pretty complex for the
platforms to navigate as well yeah yeah
they're always in a race with the
platforms for sure and the last thing is
on podcast that there seems to be this
like very big trend of taking
traditional podcast where there's very
little interaction with fans right
because it's basically a one-way
communication channel and trying to
build that community around it we see
some of the top podcasters in the world
doing everything from you know literally
live in-person shows where you can buy
tickets and show up to doing more of the
like pay and you can get access
exclusive content AMAs you know live
video but you also wrote about like
Facebook groups and things there you
know is that something where the
podcasters are trying to learn from the
influencers and the digital platforms or
are some of those people actually both
right you'd get an influencer who starts
a podcast and just naturally understands
the digital platforms yeah I mean I
think that the whole resurgence in
comcast culture is driven by this growth
and influencer culture I mean podcasters
are influencers a lot of the times there
are people that you know their fans
really look to for making decisions or
you know shaping their outlook on life
and so they have this fandom around them
that is very influenced or like fandom
where they have this close they feel
like they have this close personal
relationship with the podcaster you know
and the way that they bond with a lot of
influencers right like it's like a
youtuber that you're watching every day
also I think it's all of these youtubers
getting into the podcast world and
launching things like disk words and
Facebook groups that has you know pushed
a lot of more to maybe traditional
podcasters to also get into those types
of realms but yeah it's it's been really
interesting to see the growth in podcast
because every youtuber is starting a
podcast now and I think it's just
another way to monetize and kind of like
it's a natural thing you know it's like
a lot of them do YouTube podcast where
they cannot you know you can also watch
the person and it makes sense I'm not
you talked to hundreds if not thousands
of these influencers I can't imagine
that they are all super sophisticated
articulate mature etc what are some of
the most ridiculous stories you have of
either communicating with them because
you're doing it through like Instagram
DM and not traditional means or also
like ridiculous inbound that you get
this unsolicited yeah well I did talk to
the influencer who licked a toilet seat
in the coronavirus challenge last week
was an interesting conversation I'm
assuming that that person is not
necessarily you know showing up to a
Madison Avenue and asking for brand
deals
no but she did launch this song which
has now been streamed I think a million
times on Spotify and she's making a lot
of money because it's a it went viral on
tick-tock it's called Skinnygirl anthem
she'll love that I can't even believe
that I just even gave that a shout out
because this girl is like the number one
cloud chaser on the Internet
but and I was like I am NOT writing
about you stuff a lot of my
conversations are like I am NOT writing
about you um do they pitch you stories
like well kids literally just DM you on
a platform and be like hey will you
write a story about me oh my god Anthony
I well as you know I had to die idea
sort of deactivating my Twitter and
Instagram sometimes the amount of
messages that I get I get hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of messages a day
um almost all from young people I would
say teen age 22 and under asking for
articles they know that in order to get
verified on Instagram for instance you
need a certain amount of press in
mainstream media and so they're
literally like just out being like look
I'll talk to you or can you write a
story on me they usually have to be like
no yeah do they are they pitching like a
certain angle or story or is it
literally like just write the story on
me it's a business story it's always a
business stories always like write a
story about my business I'm doing this
write a story about how I made five
thousand dollars this summer you know
write a story about whatever rights it's
always that which is great it's
inspiring I wish I could tell all these
kids stories but I usually just I like
to hear it or I'll read it I'll read
their DM and then kind of be like if it
ladders up to something I'm writing
about a lot of kids just want to go
viral or they send me weird stuff I've
definitely gotten like a lot of
inappropriate memes but that's finest
the Internet so I'd rather over I'd
rather like be getting more messages and
have to filter through them but not be
hearing from people respond to everyone
that's genuine how do you pick which
stories to actually write like if you
have a hundred kids who DM you all these
ridiculous things like how do you pick
which one is actually the one you write
fine I don't ever really write stories I
know I don't really write many stories
about one person um that Rowan kid I
wrote about because he had sort of
like he was so intertwined in so many
things that I covered that I was like
let me just like look at this one kid
and use him as an example and so it's
usually that it's like I'll look at one
thing I want to write about some trend
and I'll kind of find some people that
fit with it um you know a lot of people
like consider me a youth reporter I
guess cuz I write about so many young
people but I really don't like skew that
way it's more like I enjoy I noticed an
interesting trend or user behavior and
then it ends up being like young people
behind it but I'll usually kind of like
lead with the interesting trend and then
try to find people that validate it or
whatever instead of the other way around
like trying to tell some kids story but
yeah which leads me to the point of like
in this weird internet culture world
like you've become somewhat of an
influencer to a lot of these kids and
even to the point where I think I saw
you tweet that you've got you know a
hundred plus thousand people on tik-tok
and and things like that like how is
that been for you as an experience of
like going from constantly writing about
it to now like hey I got a hundred
thousand people on this one platform you
know tens of thousands on Instagram four
hundred on Twitter like how does that
change the way you view the platforms
yeah I know I got four hundred thousand
on tik-tok and I was like wow this app
is so inflated I told Cory my boss that
if I get half a million I'm gonna quit
and join the be the high pass mother but
no I I don't know I mean I started on
tumblr like I was I was pretty big on
tumblr in my own sort of worlds and I
ran some popular tumblers and when I
started out I ran social media for a
bunch of really big brands so I'm
familiar with I think coming from like
the ad agency world to where you're like
speak like I kind of unfamiliar with
speaking to a lot of followers or having
that voice I guess but I would say the
thing that I don't like the most is just
how overwhelmed I get with people asking
me for things that's the main thing I
don't mind if it's kids asking me for
things but just people ask me to do
everything for them like so easy I want
to be helpful but sometimes I'm like no
I can't
you know do your whole research thing
for you you know for your company or
whatever yeah what what what did you
post on tick-tock to get 4000 followers
oh well so I honestly just was posting
like behind the scenes stuff of my job
like I mean I I'm with allotted the
thing is like I know a lot of um I know
a lot of youtubers personally I guess
through my job and I know a lot of like
tick-tock errs through my job so you
know I'll be with them at certain points
and so I've posted some like
behind-the-scenes videos of some
tick-tock errs and all of these kids
started following me and messaging me
being like how can I get your job it's
so cool and I always like to advocate
for New York Times because a lot of
these kids that's their first
introduction to the New York Times and
definitely when I was young you know I
thought that the mainstream media was so
far removed and so I always want to
respond to them
so yeah and then I you know I wrote a
story about okay boomer this tick tock
trend and a lot of kids thought that was
really funny that I was on tick tock and
so they were duetting me and then I had
a couple Subway videos go viral and I
don't know it just added up but now I'm
stuck in quarantine I don't know what
I'm gonna do my contents falling off
look there's a lot of kids who who are
in the same situation that's where I
guess they're pulling their moms and
dads and yeah I'm alone in my arrack
apartment I need to get some parents
involved awesome what I'm looking
forward to the rest of rest of this year
is it just more of kind of understanding
what those internet culture trends are
or anything else you got on the horizon
honestly the only I think you're asking
me how I pick stories I have a list of
like 80 stories and the only thing that
it slows me down is like my editor is
saying like don't focus on this or just
my me being slow kind of enough not
filing them faster so I kind of my goal
is to just you know keep writing about
the stuff that I care about and you know
trying to get some of these other
projects that I do so do a bunch of
stuff on the side so I'm trying to like
do more of that and I don't know I just
you know meet new cool people that's my
goal every year is to try to like make
new friends every year you know
like connect with new cool people every
year so just trying to do that it's hard
you know went on Twitter it's like
there's so many people coming at you and
sometimes when you you know get too much
of an audience not like $100,000 or
something is too much of a ties but
sometimes it's like you know it's hard
to make those more personal connections
so just want to make sure I'm still
meeting people even I'm stuck in this
apartment yeah there's a shortage of
people in the internet for sure
well listen I appreciate you doing this
where can people connect with you find
you I know you're kind of all over the
Internet where do you want to send them
yeah definitely just DM me anywhere on
Instagram or Twitter
I love DMS it's never weird if you slide
to my DMS I love hearing for people as
long as they're not like asking you to
do some project for them for free but
like yeah just like send me stuff or you
can email me as well my email address is
like in my bio it's just tailored
Lorenza nytimes.com so uh but but yeah
I'm just following me on Instagram and
Twitter and tic toc now III am jealous
of your your tick tock fame because I
feel like you have a a pulse on a
completely different part of the
internet that if people aren't on tick
tock they don't see it I recently pulled
up tick tock and started showing me some
of the videos and I was amazed at the
level of detail and obvious work that
went into just like somebody's dances
and stuff I was just like what people do
the dance is our next level I like
cannot I wrote this story about the girl
but created the renegade which was this
very popular dance and like she was in
her room trying to show it to me and I
was just like I forgot I could only
remember three steps of this dance also
like every kid now I feel like I can do
a backflip and I'm just like how is it
that every teenager suddenly can do it I
didn't know anyone that could do a
backflip growing up I feel like kids are
evolving or something I don't know they
probably never had to practice because
the internet wasn't air right so now all
of a sudden it's like hey I can go viral
for doing a backflip I work on doing a
backflip yeah that's true that's true
that's a good point
all right well listen I appreciate
taking time to do this
I think people will really enjoy kind of
understanding all of this and and
they'll have to do it again as more kids
do crazy stuff on the internet and keep
evolving culture yeah thank you for
having me I feel like I know you on the
internet for so long so it's been great
to chat